consacré à revitaliser le
quartier.
Camille Feireisen.
- Dans le Village, les fleurs
et les couleurs ne suffisent
plus à dissimuler les traces
de la pandémie.
- C'est un peu devenu, comme,
pendant pendant pendant la pandt
peu la cour des miracles. C'est
un petit peu, effectivement...
Bien là, en fait, juste de faire
Berri-Beaudry à pied, je me suis
fait quêter à peu près 10 fois.
- Les résidents, les commerçants
et les visiteurs ont été sondés
au cours de l'été. Maintenant,
c'est au tour des organismes
communautaires et commerciaux
de plancher sur l'avenir
de leur quartier.
Des discussions qui se tiennent
à la veille d'importants travaux
sur les réseaux d'aqueduc
et d'égoût prévus sur la rue
Sainte-Cst en 2024.
VALÉRIE PLANTE,
mairesse de Montréal
- Pour moi, c'est venu renforcer
le désir qu'on donne une cure
de jouvence, une cure
de jeunesse à notre rue
Sainte-Catherine.
- Les défis sont grands :
plusieurs locaux sont vacants
et il a fallu déployer
e de travailleurs
de rue et d'intervenants
sociaux pour aider
les populations vulnérables,
nombreuses dans le secteur,
et confrontées à un manque
de services.
GABRIELLE RONDY, DG, Société
de dével. commercial du Village
- C'est sûr qu'on a un défi
de cohabitation. C'est vraim
l'enjeu qui revient le plus
souvent quand on parle à nos
membres, cet aspect de sécurité
dans la rue Sainte-Catherine.
- Cette travailleuse de rue
espère que les discussions
permettront un véritable
dialogue entre les parties.
JULIE LAFLAMME-DESGROSEILLIERS,
trav. de rue, Spectre de Rue
- Quand on met du nouveau
mobilier urbain, bien, que
ce soit du mobilier inclusif,
donc du mobilier où les gens
peuvent dormir. On pense aux
fameux bitinérants
dont on ne veut pas,
nous, nécessairement,
dans le quartier.
- Trouver une vision commune
sera toutefois tout un jeu
d'équilibriste, reconnaît
le responsable de l'urbanisme.
ROBERT BEAUDRY, responsable de
l'Urbanisme, Ville de Montréal
- L'objectif, c'est commenton er
cet espace-là, mais en faisant
en sorte qu'on ne fasse pas
de l'écogentrification.
- Il faudra notamment attirer
de nouveçants.çants.çants.çants.
- Une boucherie, une fromagerie,
un fleuriste, un endroit
pour faire du coworking...
- Sans pour autant effacer
les marqueurs iden
et les commerces de niche qui
ont forgé, durant des décennies,
l'identité du Village. Ici Cami,
Radio-Canada, Mon